he who sows the wind harvests the storm
[Music]
better to be touched by fire than by
dishonor
whoever lets himself be led by the heart
will never lose his way
a beautiful thing is never perfect
foreign
the plant reveals what is in the seed
[Music]
at the time of a test a person Rises or
Falls
[Music]
birds of a feather flock together
[Music]
peace is the fruit of activity not of
sleep
[Music]
admitting when someone else is right is
a virtue
the one on Shore is a master swimmer
[Music]
house has the character of the man who
lives in it
[Music]
seeing someone else's problems makes
your own seem smaller
The Carpenter's door is falling apart
the worst things to be in bed and sleep
not to want for one who comes not to try
to please and please not
[Music]
suffering in search of Truth gives true
meaning to truth
he who doesn't have something doesn't
need it
the beautiful is beautiful even when
rising from sleep
but the ugly is ugly even when they wash
their face every day
[Music]
experience will show you a master can
only point the wave
one hand doesn't clap
he who has been scalded by soup blows on
yogurt
making money selling manure is better
than losing money selling Musk
friendship doubles joy and has grief
when a slave mounts a camel he wants to
ride on both humps foreign
[Music]
teaches even a donkey
protein and Prejudice distort vision
a boat with two captains will sink
[Music]
a wise person has self-control
especially when it comes to speech
no discussion can throw light on a
subject if it wanders from that subject
the seed includes all the possibilities
of the tree
[Music]
keep away from trouble and sing to it
the bald woman boasts of her niece's
hair
silence is the best answer to the stupid
[Music]
love and tell the world hate in silence
seek peacefully you will find
[Music]
every problem has a solution
[Music]
man know yourself and you shall know the
Gods
a person with a wound on his head keeps
touching it
[Music]
wise people are virtuous people
wisdom and virtue are the only paths to
happiness
[Music]
beware of him to whom you have been
charitable
each man thinks his own Horizon is the
limit of the world
Envy is the companion of great success
one foot isn't enough to walk with
a borrowed code does not keep one warm
wise people act in ways that guarantee
them a good reputation
[Music]
there is none more blind than he who
doesn't want to see
[Music]
to no means to record in one's memory
but to understand means to blend with a
thing and to assimilate it into oneself
be patient with a bad neighbor he may
move or face misfortune
[Music]
it's by your enemy hungry but never
naked
judged by cause not by effect
[Music]
what is written on the brow will
inevitably be seen by the eye
a house without a woman is like a
graveyard
great must return to the Earth die and
decompose for New Growth to begin
learn politeness from the impolite
[Music]
seek to perform your duties to your
highest ability this way your actions
will be blameless
if you search for the laws of Harmony
you will find knowledge
wise people are not overconfident they
put their trust in God
[Music]
leave him an error who loves his error
[Music]
a pupil May Show You by his own efforts
how much he deserves to learn from you
[Music]
when the Angels appear the Devils run
away
[Music]
you defy an enemy by doubting his
courage you double it
foreign
to teach one must know the nature of
those whom one is teaching
[Music]
the man who is who is a right has both
stature and the last word
[Music]
not everything with a crooked neck is a
camel
evil as well as good both operate to
advance the great plan
[Music]
the monkey is as beautiful as a gazelle
in his mother's eyes
[Music]
every man must act in the rhythm of his
time
wise people develop the disciplines of
honesty diligence gentleness and
humility
[Music]
yesterday's drunkenness will not quench
today's thirst
foreign
[Music]
through its buzzing a wasp only ends up
bringing about the destruction of its
own nest
[Music]
altruism is the mark of a superior being
for the benefit of the flowers we water
the Thorns too
what's good for the goose is good for
the gander
wise people seldom speak but when they
do they speak words that are pleasing
rather than foolish
in his own nest a beetle is a sultan
better a warm welcome than an invitation
to lunch
the only thing that is humiliating is
helplessness
foreign
for lunch before he eats you for dinner
more precious than our children are the
children of our children
the best and shortest road towards
knowledge of Truth is nature
[Music]
under the Sheikh's hat is a monkey
[Music]
stretch your legs as far as your blanket
extends
[Music]
one who cooks poison tastes it
[Music]
you want what you want he wants what he
wants but God does what he wants
[Music]
take the fare from him who is wealthy
and let pass him who is poor
[Music]
the woman who does not covet the
possessions of her husband is in love
with another man
[Music]
whoever is ashamed to sleep with his
wife will never have children
a woman will be twice bound when her
chains feel comfortable
[Music]